first I'd like to thank the organizers
for kind of inviting with this wonderful
event it's lovely to be here and for the
beautiful weather which they've arranged
for us as well so I'm Raphael clip from
us in Bristol this is a combination of
joint work sometimes just with Marcus
Giles NES and sometimes with both Marcus
Justinus and Benjamin sach I can still
feel an echo alcohol hear an echo when I
speak what so let me try and tell you
what I'm gonna talk about so this can be
talked about unconditional lower bound
so slight change from the conditional
lower bounds and generally speaking to
me about streaming problems and I'm the
talk is going to have the first half is
going to be sort of work from 2011 the
second half was going to be work from
2015 in the last half it's going to be
work for the future which is somewhat
short on the first two halves so this is
in some way the original streaming
problem I don't know how it will
recognize the characters this is
Christopher Robin here this is winnie
the pooh this is piglet and they're
playing the famous game of Poohsticks
which i think was invented somewhere
near where I'm from and in this game you
stand on a bridge over a stream and you
drop a stick each person drops a stick
on one side of the bridge and you run to
the other side of the bridge and first
person to shout out that they see their
stick come under the bridge is the
winner it's a real time problems no good
saying after the fact what I'm sure Mike
stick came first you have to shout at
first so basically it's a real time
streaming pattern matching problem and
that's the kind of thing which we try
and prove lo bands for and it's a under
a general interpretation of the word
that much because this is going to be an
unconditional lower bound talk we have
to define a computational model and for
those who don't work in the area i'll
try and find what the cell pro model is
that's the standard model now for
proving unconditional lower bounds so in
the cell pro model it is really rather
simple the idea is that you have some
memory and each cell word of memory
takes w bits and you can read and write
stuff to memory but the trick is that
all computation is free the only thing
we're to count to the number of reads
and writes to memory so imagine that the
running time for now we're the
amount of time takes do computation plus
an out of time it takes to read and
write stuff to memory so if you prove a
lower bound for one half of that some
you put a lower bound for the whole
sound so in other words the CPU as it
were the abstract CP has infinite
computational power this is infinite
which requires infinite cooling but we
don't worry about practical aspects here
this is an abstract problem but the idea
is that we're just going to try and
prove lower bounds a number of reads and
writes assuming that all computation is
free that's the general model the idea
is this gives us a lobe and someone will
give us lower bound a sliver in any
sensible model of computation that we
are interested so in particular the RAM
model has suppose I want to make a lower
bounds as general as possible that's the
model now of course lower bounds in the
soap remodel have existed for a while
for date structural problems so the cell
per model was in some sense introduced
by Minsky and Papert I think in the 60s
but really by Yau and 78 in them in the
setting that we're in stood in and did
structural problem lower bounds which
are in general to come into two
categories there are those static
problems so this is from the largely
looked at predecessor queries so in
other words you hear you pre-press the
data only that you some queries these
are query only problems we see papers by
I time Milsom paul behm and others there
and it's list and then men in 1989
really lower bounds for dynamic a
structural problems but it's kicked off
with this seminal work of Redmond and
sax who just introduced a proof
technique that people didn't have before
so they're dynamic extra problem they
took come you have queries adding up
updates the first thing of queries only
then you have queries and updates and
here we see a list papers the idea of
listen to me those papers is not so much
that you will look at each one
individually is that between 89 and the
early 2000s this is a reasonably large
proportion of all the papers that were
published in this area even though they
all in some sense use the corner Graham
technique to just having the technique
doesn't make it very simple for a
particular problem to actually got
approval lower bound there's a
significant amount of work to be done so
then
you will see and then in two thousand so
the key point about this is that the
chronic I'm technique the best possible
lower bound you can prove uses technique
is log over lock lock I should have said
that the technique simply doesn't allow
you to prove anything higher than that
generally speaking you look at log over
log log different epochs of time going
at the past you argue at least one bit
from each one of these epochs there's
nothing you can do to anything higher
than that using this technique and in
2004 the great lake genius me hyper
chesco and like to see his name being
mentioned and stop every other talk and
its workshop as it so it should be along
with the supervisor Eric domain invented
a new technique which he called the
information transfected technique and
this had two great advantages first of
all the log of log dog was sent to log
which meant that some destruction
problems and how had tight bounds
because that was the same Z upper bound
but secondly it's just a different way
of looking the problem of the proof
technique it's beautiful in my view in
some contexts lot simpler and the
technique grew into using this talk then
between 2014 and 2050 tour 2004 2015
really the next and I think the last so
far great advance was done by a Casper
Larson who showed that in some cases in
fact you could revisit the chronograph
technique and soup it up in all kinds of
clever ways in order to improve this log
in to log squared in our case our upper
bounds least with the model will be log
so we have come fortunately can't use
Casper techniques for these particular
problems but they are rather wonderful
but so let's trying to find a problem
which I'm told your problem yet other
than playing Poohsticks and then we see
what how we can what we can do so over
this first half is talking about work
from 2011 and then we'll move on so
we're going to video streaming
convolution problem mathematically more
properly it's called cross correlation
but I gave up with arguing the community
second the call it convolution and in
this problem we can have a fixed vector
here of some length so have ham sup
eight elements in it each element of
this vector in the stream comes some
range 0 to Q once one and we have a
stream that comes in one similar time
and
each time a symbol comes in we have to
output the inner product between the
fixed vector and the last n-linked
suffix of the stream and we have to do
this before the next symbol comes in so
example this number comes in we have to
output the inner product between V and X
3 2 x 10 mix all comes in after I put
the in product between V and X 4 2 x 11
and so on so forth solution is basically
how long's that take obviously naively
you could just compute the inner product
right that be if areas length of V then
it'll take you anytime so we showed this
is me and Marcus Giles Ennis now a lower
bound for this problem of delta r / w x
log in and pack only view the complete
proof for this lower bound in the next
10 to 15 minutes and here so minus stuff
we'll these things are n is the number
is the length of the vector w some bits
in a word and this delta here is the
number of bits needed to represent a
simple this is crucially important an
interesting case here's when w's like
log n because we like these words to be
big enough to be able to address memory
address and when delta is roughly the
same size as w then we have a lower
bound vlog then we're happy in fact the
technique which we use 2011 requires w
to be as big as big as log n the proof
the proof simply doesn't hold otherwise
but then later on we managed to relax
that slightly to allow stir reduce
double if we really wanted to but the
case we really care about is when
doubles like looking
but so I've already suggested of course
there's a simple linear time pro a new
symbol algorithm just going to product
but actually you can do better than that
in 2011 together with a frenetic apart
and poor at we showed a general method
for reducing a whole range of these
online problems to offline problems and
the formula you get is take the
complexity of the offline problem so in
this case this is cross correlation or
convolution so you do it by fast Fourier
transforms and n log n time offline / +
x log there's your formula so in this
case we take the n log n divided by n
multiplied it by log and we get an
algorithm which takes log squared time /
new simple every time do some comes in
takes log squared times out put the new
inner product in fact if you look back
in the Richard 1970s in reading you can
read papers using it and analyze the
context of Turing machines you'll see
that some of the ideas and here in fact
are also this paper efficient stopped my
from 73 so this so now we have this
lower bound which we'll get to prove to
you and completely of like log and upper
bound of log squared so there's a gap so
can we can we seal the gap well this is
tricky because first of all in the cell
pro model remember what computation is
free offline the algorithm is linear
time just read the data it's a very odd
thing to do soap one was not designed
for offline things but nonetheless just
read the data when you get the answer
and using the same reduction here we
just talks about to make it online we
divide by n x log and we get a log time
algorithm in the cell probe model for
the online version so in fact our lower
band when w equals Delta is tight in the
cell pro model so then you might say to
yes but this cell promoter referred you
come along with it's clearly no good get
me a better model and i'll be able to
preview a higher lower bound maybe maybe
include computation somehow but this
turns out to be tricky to because by the
same reduction any better online lower
bound and log would imply an offline
lower bound above linear
for multiplication or convolution and
that's already a significant a very
significant thing to to have done so it
seems tricky to improve this lower bound
the only route that we seem to have
available to us is to try and improve
this up about but don't attitude sir the
status there right so how I'm going to
do it we do it of course where people
that cause do things we reply as many
machs principle we're going to affect
find some random input distribution for
which there's a lower bound for any
deterministic algorithm which would
imply there exists some worst case input
distribution of deterministic can put
dispersion its upper which there's a
lower bound for any randomized I'll with
them which of course implies load bound
for any two terms together so we're
gonna focus what we actually do is this
thing up here we get is the thing down
there so we're trying to describe the
information transfer technique but first
provide do that now subscribe the
problem if you remember we talked about
data show problems which will query only
there's a static ones data expunged for
query and update but our streaming
convolution problem is neither of those
there are no queries there are only
updates so this is really a third type
of problem and it's kind of important to
understand that it's not the same as a
standard dynamic data structure problem
this is an update only problem in fact
has another feature which we relevant
later on it's an update only problem
where there aren't any indices either
when you update you don't say no update
position 23 or something you just give
it a new symbol so it's a restricted
form of update only but from TY problem
I hadn't been considered before but
nonetheless it turns out that knee highs
information transfer take the beautiful
think it is applies pretty much directly
to this model so update the system is
supposed to answer the
most recently exactly exactly exactly
exactly right yeah nope that's right no
options no queries just a symbol in
gives an apple that's it
but me has lovely method turns out
applies beautifully to this problem so
we describe to you in the way we think
about it in the subject only setting
which is just in a marginally different
for the way it's written written up but
it's the same idea just got a written
with different colors but so here you
have the memory here and we're gonna
have here's but this is the stream for
the moment we're going to set everything
with student we fix them known and
everything in our fixed effectively pics
unknown I always forget to ask i'm suing
this is green this is blue and color
blind good so symbols come in and we
give outputs because everything's fixed
them known nothing spending happening
eventually we're going to talk about we
know the region of things which we can
stay unknown they're going to be chosen
your permit random some unknown symbol
comes in remember every time if someone
comes in we give an output every single
one red when this symbol comes in we
give an output an inner product and we
should do something to do that so our
algorithm whatever it is right somewhere
in this case for example it rights to
that sale of memory you don't symbol in
its do some computation whatever it is
which is free in our case but has to
write somewhere memory to give an output
and it writes to two more sales of
memory the symbol comes it comes in
right so one more set of memory and then
another couple I think over that period
day of length L of time those symbols
that came in and also give this for
output to had to give it wrote some
stuff to memory so he reads more symbols
in daddy's gonna be fixed unknown onez
all our unknown things just as question
marks and here it reads some sets sales
of memory happens to read these two
that's fine another symbol comes in
reads another set of memory this time
happens to read one that was written in
the previous period of time does again
reads couple another one was written
before hand and we'd does it again and
what we're going to be interested in is
this set of cells here it's a set of
cells that were written in the previous
period of time with corresponds to L
inputs and read in the successive period
of time comes months L outputs and not
overwritten in between and this is
what's called the information transfer
this information is can be transferred
this period of time to that period of
time and that's going to be the key tool
that's going to be used to prove the
lower bound so first of all we need to
persuade ourselves that everything that
we need to know about this period of the
about these four symbols is encoded
information transfer we only need to
know about these cells he ran into we
don't need to know anything else about
these symbols whatsoever and we could
persuade ourselves that this then we're
going to what we're going to do is going
to argue that well we all know of course
that the entropy of any random source is
hot but not abound on the HP pendants or
anyone resources a size of encoding of
that random source of the expected sized
encoding right so we're going to argue
that the conditional entropy are the
outputs giving this period is going to
be something in terms of the expected
information transfer can be written by
two times the word size plus the word
size over there so this is going to give
us an upper bound for the entropy and
then we going to get a lower bound PHP
later on we're going to give us a lower
bound for this information transfer
that's the technique that's going to
happen now so how can we establish this
inequality here well we just give it
explicit encoding for it and the
explicit encoding is the most obvious
one you can think of for the information
transfer what we do for every cell we
restore its address and its contents w
bit speech one of those that's where the
2w comes from we also asked to store the
link to information transfer so we can
actually decode the thing so that's an
encoding now of course is it good enough
what can you actually use it can you
decode somewhere well we're saying on
encoding but can you actually decode
using it so and to persuade you can
decode let's try actually do let's do it
so mad when we have our algorithm we've
simulator album running along here the
symbols coming in and it guess at this
point here now it's going to jump over
and Karen from there all right so it
doesn't read any of those things in it
just has it has this encoding of the
information transfer so it gets this
point here every time our album does a
read it's going to look at information
transfer and see if that address it
wants to read as in the information
transfer if it is it is just read the
contents
every time it does a right okay it's
going to look in the information
transfer and see if that dress is there
if it is it wiped it out and then its
rights to the correct place in memory so
from that arguments hopefully we believe
that this encoding is sufficient to be
able to give us all the information that
we need from this unknown region in
order to answer questions correctly
afterwards now of course
this was an up man with the interview
want a low bun entry as well no this of
course depends on how facially actually
need to know about this that was subsys
airy now depends on what this fixed
vector is that exists Vic vectors for
which we don't really need to know
anything about that at all now and this
there hasn't been a lot of calling
response going on not sure if I brave
enough to do it but if film wants to
answer what be an example of fix vector
here from which we don't need to know a
single thing xirrus thank you very much
I'm very grateful so it's all zeros we
need to know anything about at all right
so you wouldn't get a lower bound at all
for the introduc disaster there are
other fix vectors which you know need to
know something but not too much imagine
that expect it was all ones well then we
certainly get something like Delta
remember Delta's the number of bits need
to represent simple its information the
first outlet here we need we need what
it's the same Delta a bits of
information for every upward afterwards
so for all four outputs all outputs we
only need Delta bits information from
this to be our to answer things
correctly anything with a small period
yes yes so we can construct though
without too much difficulty fa expected
it's going to be much better so here we
have a fixed vector with ones at power
to positions starting from the right
going left and I'll just demonstrate to
you and I'll double the link to the
unknown interval to make it easy to see
what's going on but this will get
required snow unlocked about unknown
interval so let's just look at it right
so here we give some output what it
wants to be now the symbol comes in give
some output what happens to be when
ignore these at the moment but let's get
here at some point forget situation
where there's exactly one one from the
pattern aligned in the unknown interval
at which point given remember we know
all this dark green stuff we know
everything the fix vector so given the
output we can infer exactly what that is
just like subtraction
so the output tells us precisely what
that is and the next shift along we get
to find the next symbol and make symbol
on the next symbol so we get to learn
half of the information from this
interval at least maybe the other output
sold some more stuff but don't worry
half at least so the conditional entropy
of our output is going to be at least
half of the entropy of that interval
entropy the interval of course is l
delta because each symbols got dust bits
and the uniform random so it's at least
L over 2 times Delta so now we have our
lower bound for a conditional entropy
and so what we have to do is just plug
in the upper bound lower bound and solve
and we see that the expected the
expected conditional entropy of the
information transfer is going to be at
least Delta L over 4 w minus a half so
this is great mint on a progress of
course we don't really want conditional
entropy right it's a bit funny things
being fixed but we can fix that too very
simply just by no longer fixing all the
star Queen stuff we're just making it
also a uniform and everything you'd
format them in the stream and that by
the miracle indefinitely out of
expectation we get the information
transfer has opposed to the coastal
entry information transfer gay tube amp
will get the same lobe and foot so now
we know the in that the inflation
transfer is at least Delta L 0 before W
minus half for every interval of length
L course we have to have more than one
interval AB APL right so we're going to
do about it and what you do now we want
to sum over lots of intervals length L
to get the lower bound things which
transfer for the whole thing right I
will do this using what's called the
information transfer tree we just
consider consecutive intervals of time
well a bit set of intervals of power of
two lengths and look at the information
that's transferred from each interval
two consecutive one so that's some
length one to the next one then we can
see we also have something linked to the
next one
go through this quickly so this tree
shows every every one of these nodes you
can think of having information
transferred from its left tree to its
right tree and so what we need to do is
just some the information transfer for
every one of these nodes and up to us
the total information transfer and you
might work for a second that if we just
literally summed over the node somehow
or double counting there's no double
counting kind of the easiest
non-mathematical way I think of thinking
about that it's just imagine dropping a
vertical line from each one of these
nodes and looking how many times we
count the information transferred from
the left of the rice and exactly once
for each one just some over the notes so
the expected number of cell reads is at
least the expectation of the sum of the
information transverse exists some
dictation information transfer for which
we already have this lower bound we plug
it in and we get Delta Rho W times n log
n for n inputs which gives us the
promised Delta V W times log n amortized
lower bound so that's a complete proof
for unconditional lower bound for online
convolution
so after this work 2013 now with
Benjamin sach we went on to look at the
same problem same model with Hamming
distance so now the symbols symbols are
still non-binary they won't be binary
either in the big stuff string and we
get it same lower bound but it's much
more difficult and why is it much more
difficult it's much more difficult
because you have to construct again some
bad there's some hard fixed string and
some input distribution which is going
to us high entropy for these outputs
which turned out to be relatively simple
in the case of convolution but
hamilton's is much more difficult
intuitively why is it much more
difficult because we take two symbols of
the log in bits and you ask do they
match each other that tells you one bit
of information if I multiply them gives
you much more information right this
just is just much more technically
difficult and hard distribution but
nonetheless we achieved it and which is
good and then as I say we also did some
work to see it show that actually you
could produce w from log n which this
particular proof technique doesn't allow
you to do sturms nice and we're pleased
about that and that's the state until
about 2015 let's say
but what happens if the input output is
binary bitstreams right there not such
odd things stream comes in one bit at a
time let's say our vector is finery as
well every time a new symbol comes in we
want to give an output right well the
lower bounds of Delta over w times log
in are not so good anymore because when
what log won't really want W built in
log n so we set Delta dhone we get Logan
over w if w is log n will get nothing
and there's nothing you can do about it
because they can't get more than n bit
will L bits information out of El bits
right isn't it is all you can do about
it that's just what the technique gives
you see white thing out point well
that's bad maybe I won't mention it to
anyone then you might have a look at it
and think well you know we were doing
this output sort of mod Q which what Q
was the range is its enemies here what
happens if we don't take more anything
we're just let's look at composition for
the mobile stick with condition just a
second in the products yeah the values
we output ARB don't take modern thing I
between 0 & M so potentially to have
something like log in bits of
information each output might do so
potentially if I just look at n over log
n outputs as opposed to n up puts a
level or gallery looking at the interval
length the potentially the entropy of L
over log or enable or get outputs could
be linear in it in other words maybe we
don't actually have to look at the same
length of outputs as we do inputs we can
look at some shorter length and still
learn some constant proportion of the n
bits but then if you do that of course
the proof technique doesn't work anymore
because there's no information transfer
tree anymore because these things are
not symmetric anymore and you've got
problems with double counting
potentially all the rest of it
I think I'm trying to find a problem for
which you could possibly apply these
ideas so that's what we did so then
we're going to move away from
compilation for a minute we found a
problem and the problem is called
pattern matching with address errors
it's introduced by a mere and others in
2009 I think and it goes as follows in a
classic pattern matching problem you
have two strings and you imagine some
sort of some errors we applied to these
strings and you want to know which the
are they within some distance of each
other so the air has been applied
normally to the elements of the strings
in the patent machine address or errors
idea then you imagine yourself a
telephone operator maybe subway
happening just remember to stretch and
it's not the errors are in these symbols
in the strings the arrows on the indices
and drinks the things just jumbled up
somehow let's imagine the message that
sent is 11 plus 2 and what you see
instead is 12 plus 1 a happy coincidence
nothing too bad happened as a
consequence of it but you will notice
that n plus 2 is an anagram of 12 plus 1
right this T is being moved over there w
moved over there is being moved over
here you might want to measure the
distance in these two things and that's
what they do they talk about a distance
between two anagrams essentially now the
name which they chose was l2
rearrangement distance I think I might
have called a tanagram distance because
I was too long they go and probably
speaking I mean mathematically you can
live one of these things is a
permutation the other thing if it isn't
the chances in for it I think and you
just minimize over all the possible
permutations this the sum of the squares
the distance is the Simple Touch move
let's the altie range for distance and
even concrete example the spit simply
look at may be imagined that the two
strings are 1 1 1 0 0 and 1 0 1 1 0 then
it turns out you just have to move each
bit to its nearest bit and the other
string that hasn't already been used so
this one doesn't go anywhere so you get
0 squared for listen to that one that
one goes one play
to get one squared that one goes one
because you can't picture that ones were
being used it's one squared I think the
last this zero has to give back to to
get to there and then are serious stay
still so the mail LT rate SLT agreement
remember justices together with Benjamin
sach we showed this can be solved and
again in log squared time online our
general reduction which I do black
population doesn't work with this
problem but we found another way of
making this thing online so this was in
soda 2009 so for this problem we can
solve we can solve the steps to set up
before and roll over so for binary
inputs our new lower bound is now going
to be log squared over w log log n which
interesting when W is log so that's
basically log of a log look to do this
we have to find some input distribution
so the conditional entropy the output is
high and we also had find some way of
summing these information transfer now
we drive information transfer tree
anymore without doing double that double
counting so we can actually get the full
equation transfer so maybe just a
general idea of how to do this because
it's quite technical but i'll just leave
your general general idea how we do this
so the first thing is how do you
actually how do you how do you do the
information transfer argument now just
imagine the entropy part was solved so
imagine that we've solved this part we
won't do this part when the trick is to
introduce gaps so previously we talked
about a transfer information for one in
for the set of length L to another
interval length L in this case we're
going to talk about transferring
information one interval of length L log
L to another interval of length L but
there's a gap between the two things
there's a risk that the information as
it flies from here to here might fall
down the gap and these l's are going to
be taken we can't approach we can't take
all power to length l's anymore what
they're going to be the start around
into the quarter and they go to back I
think into the half and go up and
factors of log squared and when half log
over log love with them this is why you
get log of log log rather than log in
the end but that's the general idea
we're going to try and we're going to
argue about we're going to find argue
about the amount of information that's
transferred from this interval to that
interval remember this is shorter than
that whether the gap in here and we want
to argue that it's that it's going to be
some constant proportion of our log L
information has to be transferred to the
shorter shorter region of time if we do
that then we get something very similar
what we had before so now this is the
conditional entropy of the outputs are
called ape some reason given the this is
the dark green fixed stuff is fixed you
can have an upper bound of roughly 12 2w
plus 2w times the expectation of this
thing which is the information transfer
from the first interval the second
people plus information transfer to the
gap given the fix stuff is fixed then
the lower bound we're going to have is
exactly what we want which is going to
have that the conditional entropy of the
outputs given the big stuff is fixed
it's going to be at least LOL as well
again times some constant this is the
objects here this is you can to get this
you need to find the Power Distribution
and to get this you need the new
technique
so what can we say about that well then
we're going to do the same thing by
doing expectation and we end up with
conditioning over by taking explanation
so to get rid the conditional
expectation and then we have the
information transfer so the expectation
of the information transfer is going to
be bounded below by L log n over 2w
minus this in- this transfer into the
gap so I push I would have time to
describe it to you but you have to argue
somehow they don't loose too much stuff
down the back of the sofa which you can
do it turns out it's relatively simple
if you were winched in only worst case
lower bounds it's slightly more involves
you want amortize lower bands what we do
want unless you can do that but then
it's still a bit awkward because we've
got to worry about this sort of how
we're going to do this some so we don't
double count stuff so you have to choose
so we're going to summary of all these
intervals log of a log love with them
but we don't start anywhere we want to
start so we have to find it very
carefully start some subset at the
starting times in the sum over so that
in particular it was quite fun so what
you have it basically is that some one
interval end up in the gap of the
previous interval in this hierarchy and
so you end up with this bound here so we
try and give you a clue right so that's
the technique which I kind of hand
waving my way through oh and that's a
chap dropping some information through
the gap you can just about makes it the
other side so we're going to be okay but
let me try and give you some clue and
it's light in a slightly scary slide
about um what the hard distribution is
this hard dispersions really the trick I
just like to give some idea of what the
trick is because the trick is kind of
important and the question is going to
become we use it to do any to blow bands
for any other problem some ideas are not
scary I think we scare in a second so
the stream is not too bad the stream is
just going to be a succession of four
bits blocks and each 4-bit block is
either 0 1 0 1 or 1 0 1 0 right SI
uniformly at random nice and simple
the fixed text this big strings tend to
f go to the string this is the stream is
much more complicated but never give me
some ideas about it so it's going to be
sort of sub partitioned into different
parts we have benefits of padding but
let's try and just focus on these
different parts of this big string which
I've called f1 f0 L left to of one day
left to well so and so forth it's going
to be designed in such a way that when
we're given an output remember every
time a bit comes in we give an output
the output is going to be some number
between 0 and n works adopting 0 an
excuse some number log in bits it's
example output let's say the apples 9
and what would you do some house we want
to argue that every output tells us
about login bits of the stream so we're
going to look at the separate bits of
the output this the bits number 9 is
1001 hopefully soon remember it's
correct and what we've done is we
construct this fixed string in such a
way because these all going to have some
exponentially different scales in some
sense which I would have time to explain
that the contribution to this output is
going to be X finish different scales so
this this thing here depending on what
this bit of this stream is whether it's
1 0 1 0 or 0 1 0 0 0 1 will contribute
to the first bit and this thing here
I'll contribute to the second bit of the
output and this will tribute to the next
bit of the output and this contribute to
the next bit of the output because
cutting right to left there so by by
designing this thing very carefully we
can ensure that the individual bits in
the output I'm going to tell us 4-bit
blocks in the stream each four o'clock
has any HP one because any of the option
of being one two possibilities
so we we were able to argue that you
could recover some constant fraction of
log n bits of the stream from each one
of these outputs that's the basic idea
of how it works for LT rearrangement and
have discussed more details anytime
anyone wants to know so that's the end
of the LT Richard part we're able to get
designed this new technique involving
the gap the slop side its darkness this
rather tricky were hard distribution
which enables us to use the individual
bits of the output till a separate bits
of the stream so let's to finish let's
go back to what's the first question
what happened to convolution right now
we'll have sudden stop talking about
convolution now we've moved from 2000m
2015 now moving to the future this turns
out to be rather difficult perhaps
surprisingly so
let's imagine that the input is binary
uniform at random right fundamentally it
turns out to be this simple mathematical
question which I'll for make slightly
more exactly a second turns out to be
very difficult to solve what is the
entropy of n over log n consecutive
inner products where consecutive means
you slide your fixed vector on by one
now I believe its linear but it doesn't
seem at all obvious how to prove it and
anybody has any ideas how do I love to
hear it sizzle so let's put it slightly
more mathematically let's imagine that
our stream is just one more 1 0 1 1 1 1
and n is 4 so the consecutive windows
we're going to in approach where they're
going to be 1 110 the next one here is 1
1 0 1 then 1 0 1 1 right so we can write
those as rows of a matrix from bottom up
if this thing we have some random
variable here which is just binary
vector length L chose me off from it
random do there exist l over log l by l
by which i mean for a kind of all L
let's say we're noon for number of l's
toeplitz matrix the listings tirpitz
because the falling diagonals are
constant so whenever you do this thing
with these sliding windows let this road
you're going to the Tirpitz matrix such
the entropy of MX is linear there's the
open problem straight math question
which doesn't seem at all of this at
least me
and thank you very much
hhp hench me
did one flick up I was a joke on
terminal
hey answers have universally conjecture
just throw mentally yeah a lot and we do
it seems true I can't find any evidence
that suggests it's not true that's as
far as you could do right